could the second wave be on the turn
the latest data from the office of
national statistics the most reliable
tracker of the epidemic suggests
cases are stabilizing across england a
little under 619
000 people had the virus in the last
week of october that's up from just
568 000 the week before
that works out at one in every 90 people
but the number of new infections has
dropped an average of 45
700 a day last week down from almost
52 000 the week before as you can see
infections have been rising steeply
since september
so this is a sudden turnaround the
regional breakdown
holds some clues on why rates in much of
england are rising as they are
in scotland wales and northern ireland
too but in the northeast
infections have plateaued for several
weeks
and in the northwest there's been a
sharp dip now one week's data
doesn't make a trend of course but
millions of people in the hot spots have
been living under significant
restrictions for some time
so it's possible that the spread of the
virus has slowed
that doesn't yet show up in the official
r number the measure of the rate of
spread
it's unchanged since last week between
1.1 and 1.3
suggesting the epidemic nationally is
still growing
what happens next depends on the success
of the lockdown
data suggests people are still moving
around in a big way
on thursday the number of vehicles on
the road that the rac
black boxes fell by just three percent
and compare that to day one of the
spring let down when the number
fell by 13 schools universities and many
more shops are still
open this time round but that gives the
virus more of a chance to spread
and there's a worrying development in
denmark too a strain of covid has
jumped from mink farmed for the fur
now has jumped back to humans with at
least 12 people infected
could the danish prime minister be right
that the mutated strain
threatens the effectiveness of the
vaccine scientists don't know yet
it depends how much it's changed so one
one small change is probably not going
to have any impact
on on the vaccines based on the spike
protein
it depends whether some of these candida
vaccines are using the entire protein
some are using just a portion of it
depends where that change is depends how
many changes there are
authorities aren't taking any chances
millions of mink are being culled
part of denmark is in lockdown and the
uk government has immediately ordered
anybody coming back from the country to
quarantine
we're on the verge of rolling out the
first vaccine
a shape-shifting virus is the last thing
we need